okay
alright
shepard did everything right more than
we could have hoped for
commander shepard uncovered the truth
and still it's not enough
we're at war
no one wants to admit it but humanity is
under attack
but they're sending him to fight geth
geth
we both know they're not the real threat
the reapers are still out there
and it's up to us to stop them
the council will never trust cerberus
they'll never accept our help even after
everything humanity has accomplished
but shepard
they'll follow him
he's a hero a bloody
icon but he's just one man if we lose
shepherd humanity might well follow
then see to it that we don't lose him
disengaging ftl drives
emission sinks active
board is green we are running silent
we're wasting our time
four days searching up and down this
sector and we haven't found any sign of
geth activity
three ships went missing here in the
past month
something happened to him my money's on
slavers the terminus system is crawling
with them
picking up something on the long range
scanner
unidentified vessel
looks like a cruiser doesn't match any
known signatures
cruiser is changing course
now on intercept trajectory
stealth systems are engaged there's no
way a guest ship could possibly it's not
the gap brace pervasive maneuvers
somebody get that fire out
wow
the alliance won't abandon us
we just need to hold on
get everyone onto the escape shop
joker's still in the cockpit he won't
evacuate i'm not leaving either
i need you to get the crew onto the evac
shuttle
i'll take care of joker
viara go
now
everybody in go go
so
[Music]
mayday
mayday normandy
we've suffered heavy damage from an
unknown enemy
a baby
come on joker
we have to get out of here
no i won't abandon the normandy i can
still save her
the normandy's lost
going down with the ship won't change
that
yeah okay help me up
uh
[Music]
commander shepard has been recovered
the lazarus project will proceed as
planned
[Music]
um
something's wrong
he's reacting to outside stimuli
showing an awareness of his surroundings
oh my god miranda i think he's waking up
damn it wilson he's not ready yet give
him the sedative
shepherd don't try to move just lie
still try to stay calm
still climbing brain activity is off the
charts
it's not working
[Music]
heart rate dropping
stats falling back into normal range
that was too close we almost lost it i
told you your estimates were off
run the numbers again
wake up commander
shepard do
this facility is
this pistol doesn't have a thermal clip
looks like they set up a barricade to
try holding the mechs off
look out
[Music]
nice work
um
use the grenade
take the elevator down one floor
hurry get to the door
i just wish
we've moved from simple organic
reconstruction of the subject to
biosynthetic fusion
initial results
director she should be ecstatic at all
the progress we've made
but she's still the same old ice queen
maybe she's worried
what are you doing here i thought you
were still a work in progress
i just woke up you probably know more
than i do
right sorry about that i'm jacob taylor
i've been stationed here for hostiles
detected
damn it
things must be worse than i thought if
miranda's got you running around i'll
fill you in but we better get you to the
shuttle first
it's your station jake i'll follow you
the first step let's finish off these
metal bastards we're low on thermal
clips but i'm a biotic just give the
order when you want me to hit him with
the good stuff
falling back
ready to get the hell off this station
before we go anywhere i need some
answers
sure what do you want to know
the last thing i remember is the
normandy blowing up
did anyone else make it
just about everybody survived a few
servicemen from the lower decks didn't
get out
navigator presley was killed by an
explosion but everyone else including
the non-alliance crew the asari liara
and the quarian they all made it out
alive
you know what any of them are doing now
i don't know commander it's been two
years
they've moved on
left the alliance
could be anywhere
they were my team
if they knew i was alive they'd come
back
maybe you can track them down after we
get off the station
if we get off the station
what's the quickest way to those
shuttles
depends where the mechs are thickest
it's probably best if we check check
anyone on this frequency
anybody still alive out there hello
wilson
this is jacob here with commander
shepard just took out a wave of mechs
over in d-wig shepard's alive
never mind you need to get him out of
there get to the service and head for
the network control room
roger that wilson stay on this frequency
i think i remember wilson checking on me
one time when i woke up
that's him
he's the chief medical tech answers
directly to miranda come on service
tunnels are this way
we've been spotted damn it wilson this
room is crawling his mouth
preferably one that doesn't lead
straight into an enemy squad
wilson where are you
this physical reconstruction of subject
is complete but we still need to
evaluate all mental and neurological
functions
our orders were clear
make commander shepard who he was before
the explosion
the same mind the same morals the same
personality if we alter his identity in
any way if he's somehow not the man he
used to be
the lazarus project would have failed
shepard down here bastards got me in a
leg you were there the first time i
regained consciousness
yeah
that was me
how about we talk about this after we
fix my leg should be some meta gel in
the first aid station on the wall
hopefully there's enough to get him up
and moving again grab the medigel from
the first aid station on the wall
wilson's hurt bad he needs help
thanks shepard
never thought you'd save my life
guess that makes us even now
i thought maybe i could shut down the
security mix but whoever did this fried
the whole system
completely irreversible we didn't ask
what you were doing why do you even have
security mech clearance you were in the
bio wing weren't you listening
i came here to try and fix this
besides i was shot
how do you explain that
you're all strangers to me
let's get someplace safe then we'll sort
out whose fault it is right shepard we
need to find miranda we can't leave her
behind forget about miranda she was over
in d-wing the mechs were all over that
sector
there's no way she survived a bunch of
mechs won't drop miranda she's alive
where is she
why haven't we heard from her there are
only two possible explanations
she's either dead or she's a traitor
then why did you wake me up and warn me
about the attack
okay maybe she's not a traitor but that
doesn't change the facts
we're here she's not we need to save
ourselves
the shuttle bay is only a few
that's it let's get out of here
okay we took him down but this is
getting tense
shepard if i tell you who we work for
you trust me this really isn't the time
jacob we won't make it if he's expecting
a shot in the back if you want to piss
off the boss it's your ass jacob the
lazarus project the program that rebuilt
you it's funded and controlled by
cerberus
i wiped out my share of cerberus
projects when i was a spec
back then they were trying to kill me
why the change of heart
those answers are way above my pay grade
but basically
things change the alliance declared
you're dead they gave up cerberus spent
a fortune to bring you
back look i'd be suspicious too but
right now we have to work together i
thought you deserve to know what's what
once we're off the station i'll take you
to the elusive man he'll explain
everything
i promise
elusive man is he in charge of all this
yeah that's not his real name of course
nobody knows who he really is it was a
code name the alliance used for him
kind of stuck
i don't care what his name is he just
needs to answer my questions
all of them
he spent a lot of money and time
bringing you back
i'm sure he'll be
big scenes
uh
test subject has been recovered but the
damage is far worse than we initially
feared
in addition to the expected burns and
internal injuries from the explosion
subject has suffered significant
cellular breakdown due to long-term
exposure to vacuum and sub-zero
temperatures
despite the extent of the physical
trauma wilson assures me subject is
salvageable the lazarus project will
proceed as planned
test subject has been recovered but the
damage is far worse than we initially
feared
come on through here we're almost at the
miranda but you are
dead
what the hell are you doing
my job
wilson betrayed us all
if you say so what's our next step we
get on the shuttle and go my boss wants
to speak to you you mean the elusive man
i know you work for cerberus
ah jacob i should have known your
conscience would get the better of you
lying to the commander isn't the way to
get him to join our cause well since
we're getting everything out in the open
is there anything else you want to ask
before we go commander
what about the rest of the people on the
station
this is the evac area if they're not
here now they're not coming
we can't leave without knowing for sure
we need to go back and look
don't you get it
the only one worth saving is you
everyone else is expendable she's right
we all knew the risks when we signed up
without you there's no point to any of
this
you're the lazarus project's director
aren't you that's right i put two years
of my life into this project
into you what does cerberus want from me
maybe you should ask the elusive man
when you meet him he poured virtually
unlimited resources into lazarus
obviously he has some kind of plan for
you
i've had enough of this station to last
a lifetime
or two in your case
come on
[Music]
before you meet with the elusive man we
need to ask a few questions to evaluate
your condition
what we have to do this now we should
have done weeks of testing to confirm
the success of project lazarus
a few questions during the shuttle ride
will have to suffice
okay
records show you grew up on earth
tough environment no parents
you enlisted and you survived a thresher
maw attack that wiped out the rest of
your team
do you remember that
i lost a lot of friends that day
going through something like that
changes you
it can break you if you let it
i read the report 50 marines died in a
cruise you were the only one who lived
satisfied miranda almost
let's try something more recent
vermeier where you destroyed seren's
cloning facility
you had to leave one of your squad
behind to die in the blast
lieutenant caden elenko was killed in
action it was your call
why did you leave him behind
i left a friend to die that day and i
didn't do it casually
but i had to save as many people as i
could caden gave his life for the rest
of the team without him i couldn't have
stopped sarin
he died a hero i understand commander
and i wasn't judging your decision
everybody at cerberus knows that cloning
facility had to be destroyed there are
other tests we really should run
come on miranda enough with the quizzes
the memories are there and i can vouch
for shepard's combat skills personally i
suppose you're right
we'll have to hope the elusive man
accepts our little field test as
evidence enough
the elusive man is waiting for you in
the other room
so
foreign
commander shepard
elusive man
i thought we'd be meeting face to face
unnecessary precaution
not unusual for people who know what you
and i know
you might be the reason i'm still alive
but that doesn't mean i trust you you
need to put your personal feelings aside
humanity is up against the greatest
threat of our brief existence
the reapers good to see your memories
still intact how are you feeling
cut to the chase
what are the reapers doing that made you
decide to bring me back
we're at war
no one wants to admit it but humanity is
under attack while you've been sleeping
entire colonies have been disappearing
human colonies
we believe it's someone working for the
reapers just as saren and the geth aided
sovereign you've seen it yourself
you bested all of them that's just one
reason we chose you
nothing you say is going to convince me
to trust you i need more than words
i'd be disappointed if i could persuade
you that easily
go and see for yourself
i have a shuttle ready to take you to
freedom's progress the latest colony to
be abducted
miranda and jacob will brief you
what do you think i'll find there
if i knew that i wouldn't need to send
you find any clues you can who's
abducting the colonies do they have any
connection to the reapers
i brought you back
it's up to you to do the rest
the elusive man is very impressed with
you
i'm eager to see if you can live up to
his expectations on this mission
don't worry we'll find out what happened
to those colonists well at least you're
confident
let's hope it's not misplaced
for someone who spent two years putting
me back together you don't seem real
fond of me
i have the utmost respect for your
abilities shepard it's your motivations
that concern me i believe in what
cerberus stands for
only time will tell if you prove to be
an asset or a liability to our cause
what can you tell me about this colony
we're going to
freedom's progress it's a typical human
settlement in the terminus systems they
had a small military force for
protection supplemented by mechs and
security drones average in almost every
way really
completely unremarkable
until the disappearance
any thoughts on what we might run into
there
a lot of empty buildings and one giant
mystery it's obvious you're not
interested in talking
we've got an assignment we can talk
about it or we can do it
[Music]
we should be there shortly shepard the
elusive man put us under your command do
you have any orders
her first priority is to look for
survivors
that's unlikely commander
no one was left at the other colonies
they were completely deserted be nice to
find somebody
anything's better than another ghost
town
switch up brian looks like everyone just
got up and left right in the middle of
dinner
strange
no bodies no structural damage
no signs of battle
hear that sounds like that
strange security systems were disabled
with the other colonies
i've got
shoot them before they take out the
shield
um
someone reprogrammed them to attack on
site we're not alone here
so
you said you'd let me handle this
wait
shepherd i'm not taking any chances with
cerberus operatives put those weapons
down
shepard
is that
you're alive cerberus rebuilt me tally
in return they asked me to investigate
these attacks on human colonies
you'll pardon us for not taking you at
your words cerberus we're well within
our rights to investigate attacks on a
human colony i'd like to know what the
quarians are doing here weapons down
prasa whatever's going on here i don't
think we need another fight
one of our people was here on pilgrimage
his name was vitor we came to find him
isn't that a little strange
a quarian visiting a remote human colony
quarians can choose where they go on
pilgrimage vitor liked the idea of
helping a small settlement he was always
nervous in crowds
she means that he was unstable combine
that with damage to his co2 scrubbers
and an infection from an open-air
exposure and he's likely delirious
when he saw us landing he hid in a
warehouse on the far side of town we
suspect he also programmed the mechs to
attack anything that moved
vitor is the only one who can tell us
what happened here we should work
together to find him
good idea you'll need two teams to get
past the drones anyway now we're working
with servers no praza you're working for
me if you can't follow orders go wait on
the ship
head for the warehouse through the
center of the colony
we'll circle around the far side and
draw off some of the drones to clear you
a path
make sure to keep in radio contact will
do good luck shepard see you on the far
side
thanks for the warning we'll take care
we've been spotted
so
use overload on them
[__] it down
one last
we should have expected this come on we
can still catch them
ah
let's grab them
we'll take cover by the doors shepherd
you take point
right
you got it
ah
that mac's got heavy armor plating those
quarians never stood a chance
this is going to be one tough son of a
[__] to take down
overload will take out their shield
ugh
monsters coming back
max will protect safe from swarms have
to hide no monsters no swarms
no no no no no
no vetoer not here swarms can't find
monsters coming have to hide hey i'm
talking to you
great we come all this way and our only
witness is a babbling idiot
swarm's coming storm coming storm of
swarms
mechs will protect have to hide have to
hide no escape can't hide forever swarms
will find you monsters find you no hope
no escape vitor
i'm here to protect you i won't let the
monsters get you i promise
to hide have to hide mex will protect
swarm's coming
you're human
where did you hide
how come they didn't find you
who didn't find us the
the monsters
the swarms
they took everyone why didn't the
colonists fight back vitor what happened
you don't know
you didn't see
but i see everything
looks like security footage he must have
pieced it together manually what the
hell is that
my god
i think it's a collector
is that some kind of alien there are
species from somewhere beyond the omega
4 relay
only a few people have ever seen one in
person they usually work through
intermediaries like slavers or hired
mercenaries if they're involved with the
reapers somehow it could explain what
happened to the colonies
the collectors have advanced technology
they could have a weapon that disables
an entire settlement at once
the seeker swarms
no one can hide
the seekers find you freeze you
then the monsters take you away
what happened next
the monsters took the people onto the
ship and then they left
the ship flew away
but they'll be back for me no one
escapes i think that's probably all
we're getting out of him commander
we appreciate what you told us you were
very helpful i studied them the monsters
the swarms
i recorded them with my omni tool lots
of readings electromagnetic dark energy
we need to get this data to the elusive
man grab the quarry and call the shuttle
to come pick us up
what vitor is injured he needs treatment
not an interrogation we won't hurt him
we just need to see if he knows anything
else he'll be returned unharmed your
people tried to betray us once already
if we give him to you we'll never get
the intel we need praza was an idiot and
he and his men paid for it
you're welcome to take vitor's omni tool
data but please just let me take him
you don't have to take vitor and go we
could work together just like old times
i'm still trying to accept that you're
even alive
and you're with cerberus
i've got responsibilities now i've got a
mission of my own i can't walk away from
that
not even for you
he's traumatized and he needs medical
care tally will give us the omnitool
data and take him to the flotilla
understood commander
thank you shepard
i'm glad you're still the one giving the
orders good luck out there if i find
anything that can help you i'll let you
know
we're ready for pickup
shepard good work on freedom's progress
the quarians forwarded their findings
from vidor's debriefing no new data but
it's a surprising olive branch given our
history you and i have different methods
but i can't argue with your results
the data from his omni tool should be
quite useful
we're still analyzing it but more
importantly you confirm the collectors
are behind the
abductions why do i get the feeling you
knew about them already
i had my suspicions but i needed proof
the collectors are enigmatic at best
they periodically travel to the terminus
systems looking to gather seemingly
unimportant items or specimens usually
in exchange for their technology when
their transactions are complete they
disappear as quickly as they arrived
back beyond the unmapped omega-4 relay
until now we've had no evidence of
direct aggression by the collectors
why is the omega-4 relay on matt
what do we know about it
only that no ship passing through it has
ever returned
our best guess is that the relay reacts
differently to collector vessels
allowing them safe passage if they can
manipulate relays that's just further
evidence of the connection with the
reapers
the collectors are definitely a human
enemy but how do we know there's a
connection to the reapers their focus
shifted to humanity only after you and
the human fleet destroyed sovereign the
abductions are related even if the
alliance and the council refuse to
believe it
i won't wait until the reapers are on
the march we need to take the fight to
them
i hate waiting but i'll need a team a
good one
i've already compiled a list of soldiers
scientists and mercenaries you'll get
dossiers on the best of them finding
them and convincing them to work with
you could be challenging but you're a
natural leader i'll continue to track
the collectors when they make their next
appearance i'll notify you and your team
be ready
you worry about the collectors i'll make
sure my team's ready
good
two things before you go
first head to omega and find morton
solas he's a brilliant solarian
scientist
our intelligence suggests he may know
how to counteract the collector's
paralyzing seeker swarms
sounds good what else
i found a pilot i think you might like i
hear he's one of the best someone you
can trust
hey commander
just like old times huh
i can't believe it's you joker look
who's talking i saw you get spaced got
lucky with a lot of strings attached
how'd you get here
it all fell apart without you commander
everything you stirred up the council
just wanted it gone the team was broken
up record sealed and i was grounded
the alliance took away the one thing
that mattered to me hell yeah i joined
cerberus you really trust the elusive
man
i don't trust anyone who makes more than
i do but they aren't all bad
saved your life
let me fly
and there's this
they only told me last night
[Music]
it's good to be home huh commander
i guess we'll have to give her a name
so
[Music]
you